[Music]
my name is Peter Biggs and I'm the chief
executive of Antarctica New Zealand the
New Zealand government agency that's
responsible for New Zealand's affairs
and Antarctica including the running of
Scott base in New Zealand science
program one of the best things about
this series is gives us an ability to
outreach to many people about how
Antarctica is changing it's very easy to
do beautiful images and of the wildlife
and of the scenery but to understand
what that science is telling us is
hugely important
it's very important to me as a father
that my children can see things that I
can't actually show them and that is how
Antarctica is changing how does
responding to a change in global climate
yeah I think the emperor penguins is
that the taller ones and they're also
the ones that are part of the Antarctica
New Zealand logo is so curious and they
have got a character we sometimes lambda
helicopters on the edge of the sea ice
and the emperor penguins will come and
defend the helicopter and we can't
actually start the helicopter up until
we have to shoo the the penguins away so
very difficult it's fun because they're
so interested in the helicopter for
whatever reason but it's fun being with
them the curiosity is incredible
[Music]
[Music]